the real toll of this war for russia
unclaimed body bags stacked in
refrigerated trains
soldiers dead on the front line as
russia claims to rescue the
russian-speaking population living here
ukraine says about 25 000 have lost
their lives so far
but russia puts that number at about
1300.
we were given rare access to the bodies
left behind as russia retreated from the
kiev region
he was an elite paratrooper
this jewelry was found on him allegedly
stolen from ukrainian civilians
ukraine treats the dead enemies better
than how they treated civilians they
will be kept as long as need be the
government will decide because russia
refuses to take them it doesn't want
them each body is a proof of a war crime
so if they refuse to take them ukraine
will bury them at our own cost
the war is in his third month but so far
moscow has no clear victory to show for
it
even in predominantly russian-speaking
mariopol where it did enjoy some popular
support in the past
now evgeny sosnovsky says those voices
are gone he just came out of the port
city two days ago
i was cycling past the destroyed theater
building i noticed that they were
clearing the main avenue and the central
square perhaps they were preparing for
this seal called victory parade
but i also could still see the blue and
yellow of the ukrainian flag
and vendors are refusing to sell goods
in ruble only ukrainian currency
evgeny has documented life under
occupation as much as he could without
getting detected by soldiers
hardly the image of a liberated people
the kremlin want to portray
after failing to take keefe russia has
concentrated its air power on destroying
ukraine's infrastructure in what it
called a special military operation but
so far more than 3 000 civilians have
lost their lives and the human cost for
both sides is rising by the day
olga is among the millions displaced by
the conflict she's also just made it to
safety with her two young children and
mother
before their arrival life was good we
had a beautiful city parks everyone had
life plans
work freedom of choice of language
freedom of movement freedom of thought
we lived freely then russia came to
rescue us they liberated us from our
houses our jobs some of their lives some
of their legs or arms that deliberation
olga has now switched to the ukrainian
language with her children
while russia celebrates its victory
against nazi germany at the end of world
war ii
it is now in battle in a war that didn't
go as expected
al jazeera keith